Professor Paul Bloom:
Let me begin by just reminding
us where we are in this course,
reminding us of what we've done
and what we have yet to do.
We started by talking about the
brain, the physical basis of
thought.
And then we moved to some
general introductions to some
foundational ideas in the study
of psychology,
Freud and Skinner.
We spent a bit of time on more
cognitive stuff:
development,
language, vision,
memory.
Then we took a little break and
the dean told us about love.
Then we dealt with the
emotions, rationality,
and evolution,
and a lot of that.
What we learned particularly
regarding the evolution of the
mind provided supporting
material for what follows.
We learned about cognitive
neuroscience using the study of
face recognition as an important
case study--human differences,
behavioral genetics,
nature and nurture,
sex and food.
My lecture was on sex.
Dr.
Brownell came and spoke to us
about food.
Today, morality.
Next week, social thought and
social behavior,
mysteries;
basically, a series of topics
that don't fit anywhere in the
course and really make
psychologists scratch their
heads.
These topics are sleep,
laughter, and religion,
mental illness,
two lectures on madness,
what can go wrong in your
minds, and a last lecture on
happiness.
And then you're just done.
You know a lot of psychology
and a lot of stuff and you're
well prepared for your ultimate
major in psychology,
ultimately graduate training at
a good school.
How many people here are either
psych majors or expect to become
psych majors or cognitive
science as though you could
raise your hand to?
Okay.
Good.
It's nowhere near enough
[laughter]
and so I'll ask the question
again.
Once you deal with happiness
and then mysteries,
you're really not going to want
to--What is there?
Chemistry?
Anthropology?
[laughter] Pre-med?
Give me a break.
[laughter] Okay.
We're going to deal with three
facets of morality.
I'm going to talk about moral
feelings, moral judgments,
and then moral action with
particular focus on why good
people do bad things,
which will lead us to review
and discuss the Milgram study,
which was presented in the
movie on Monday.
Now, moral feeling is what
we'll start off with and we've
already discussed this in a
different context.
The question is,
'How could moral feelings
evolve?"
So, moral feelings we could
view as feelings of
condemnation,
shame, emotions like
that--shame,
condemnation,
pride, righteous anger,
but also simple affection,
caring for other people,
wanting to do well by them,
being upset if an injustice is
to be done by them.
And you might think that the
existence of these feelings is a
mystery from an evolutionary
point of view.
If evolution is survival of the
fittest, nature red in tooth and
claw, how could animals evolve
moral feelings?
But in fact,
we know the answer to this.
And there are two answers to
this.
One answer is kin selection.
So, evolution works at a level
of the genes and because of that
it could give rise to animals
that are themselves altruistic.
And they're altruistic because
they act to preserve other
animals that share the same
genes.
And so, I'm not going to spend
any time on this because we've
discussed it in detail,
but we know from previous
lectures that people will be
generous to others.
And there's an evolutionary
explanation for your generosity
towards kin.
It could be mathematically
worked out.
Your caring,
your moral feelings towards
other creatures to the extent of
the proportion of genes that you
share with them.
The most altruistic behavior of
all, giving your life to help
another, can be explained in
cold-blooded evolutionary terms.
Animals that are altruistic
even to the point of dying to
help another,
those genes will,
under some circumstances,
be preserved over the genes of
people who are less caring.
And that is one force towards
kindness.
A second force towards kindness
is cooperation.
Even if animals are unrelated,
they are nice to one another.
Animals will give warning
cries, they will groom one
another, they will exchange
food,
and the reason for this is that
animals have evolved,
our minds have evolved,
to enter into sort of
cooperative situations with
other people and to surmount
prisoner's dilemmas,
to surmount deception and
cheating.
This gives rise to some emotion
including emotions that could be
viewed as moral emotions,
like guilt and anger,
and again, grounds altruistic
behavior in an evolutionary
perspective.
This is all by means of review
but the question you can now ask
is, "Fine.
That's why moral feelings might
evolve, but what do we know as
psychologists about the
emergence in nature of moral
feelings in individuals?
What's the psychology of moral
feeling?"
And this is an issue I'm going
to talk about now but I'm going
to return to next week when we
deal with issues such as liking
and disliking,
racial prejudice and other
things.
But I want to deal now with a
couple of interesting case
studies about moral feelings
from a psychological point of
view.
The first one I want to deal
with is empathy.
And empathy has different
definitions but we can simply
view it as the feeling that your
pain matters to me.
If you are hurt,
that is, in some sense,
painful for me.
If you are sad,
that affects my own mood.
I am not a selfish creature.
I am built, I am hard wired,
to be attuned to your pain.
This is an old observation.
Adam Smith, who is often
falsely viewed as a proponent of
selfishness and hardheadedness,
was quite explicit about the
pull this has.
He notes:
When we see a stroke
aimed and just ready to fall
upon the leg or arm of another
person,
we naturally shrink and draw
back our own leg or arm and when
it does fall we feel it in some
measure and are hurt by it as
well as the sufferer.
If you see somebody being
kicked in the groin in a movie,
you might yourself tense up.
If you see somebody bang their
thumb with a hammer,
you might cringe.
Here is a good illustration of
somebody in anticipatory pain.
[laughter]
Now--It's a very British face
actually.
[laughter]
Now, we know certain things
about this empathy,
some which might be surprising.
The pain of others is aversive
even for babies.
We know this because if babies
hear other babies crying they
will get upset.
The crying of babies is
aversive to babies.
Now, some of you may be
sufficiently cynical to say,
"That could be explained in
other ways.
For one thing,
one theory is that babies hear
other babies cry,
because babies are so stupid
they think they themselves are
crying;
if they're crying they must be
in some sort of pain so they cry
some more."
But clever psychologists have
ruled this out.
What they did was a study where
they exposed babies to
tape-recorded sounds of other
babies crying and tape recorded
sounds of themselves crying.
Babies cry more to this pain of
other babies than they do to
their own pain,
suggesting that their response
is to some extent a response to
the "otherness" of the
characters.
We know pain is--of others is
aversive for chimpanzees and we
know this in certain ways.
But we know this,
in particular,
from a series of studies that
would be unethical if they were
to be done today.
In these studies,
they put a chimpanzee in a room
and there's a lever.
And when the chimpanzee slaps
the lever, it gets some food.
Trivial, smart animal,
piece of cake.
But the room has a window
leading to another room.
And in the other room another
chimpanzee is placed.
This second chimpanzee is not a
relative of the first chimpanzee
and they've never seen each
other before.
Now, when the first chimpanzee
hits the lever the second
chimpanzee gets a painful
electric shock,
putting the first chimpanzee in
a horrible dilemma.
In order to feed himself,
he has to torture another
animal.
Chimpanzees do not starve
themselves to death.
It's very unlikely any of you
would either but they go a long
time without food,
suggesting they do not want to
cause this other chimpanzee
pain.
It only works within species.
So, in another experiment they
put a rabbit in the other room
and the chimpanzee would slap
the lever repeatedly to make the
rabbit scream in pain [laughter]
and jump.
Now, we've known for a long
time that empathetic feeling is
not logically linked to
morality.
This is a point made by
Aristotle.
I could see you writhing in
pain.
That could cause me pain but it
doesn't mean I'm going to be
nice to you.
I could run away from you.
I could turn my head or I could
blame you for causing me this
misery.
But it does happen that
emotional--that this sort of
empathy does lead to moral
concern and action.
If we do an experiment and we
induce you to feel empathetic to
somebody, we get you to feel
what they're feeling,
you're more likely to be nice
to them.
And people differ in the extent
to which they feel empathy.
People differ to the extent it
will hurt them to watch me slam
my thumb with a hammer.
If you are high empathy,
you're more likely to be a nice
person than if you're low
empathy,
suggesting there is some
connection between empathetic
feeling and liking.
Now, empathetic feeling,
like any other human capacity,
differs across people.
Some of us have a lot of it.
Some of us don't have much of
it.
There is some reason to believe
that in the population known as
"psychopaths,"
a population we'll return to
later on when we discuss mental
illness, this sort of
instinctive empathy is broken
and the pain of others just
doesn't bother them very much.
I have some illustrative quotes
here.
In Damon's book,
a wonderful book on
psychopathy, he talks about a
thirteen-year-old mugger who
specialized in mugging blind
people.
And when asked about the pain
he caused his victims he
responded, "What do I care?
I'm not her," which is
logically correct but,
in a sense, inhuman.
The fact that it's another
person should make you care.
The serial killer Gary Gilmore
basically said the pain of
others gratified him and caused
him no unhappiness at all.
"I was always capable of murder.
I can become totally devoid of
feelings of others,
unemotional.
I know I'm doing something
grossly--" and here is a very
bad word "--wrong.
I can still go ahead and do it."
And Ted Bundy,
when interviewed at one point,
said he was astonished that
people made such a fuss about
all of his murders because he
said,
"I mean, there are so many
people."
And if any of you here are
nodding in agreement at these
sentiments, [laughter]
that's not such a good sign.
These are particularly callous
and cold-blooded statements
suggesting that this instinctive
empathy,
this aspect of moral thought,
is not--is present in most of
us but not in all of us.
The second case study of moral
feeling is "in-group" and
"out-group."
In our affections,
in our caring,
who we like,
who we feel close to,
whose pain bothers us,
we are not indiscriminate.
I care a lot more about my
children than I do about my
friends and I care more about my
friends than I care about
strangers.
We're all like that.
We also favor our group over
others in every possible way.
You are a member of many groups.
You are men.
You are women.
You're Yale students.
You're young.
You're white,
you're black,
you're Asian.
You're a member of these groups
and, as we will discuss
repeatedly when we talk about
social cognition and social
behavior,
this membership matters a lot
to you.
What's particularly interesting
is even groups that are formed,
that you were not born with,
that are formed on the fly,
exert a huge amount of control
over your moral feelings and
moral attitudes.
And the best example of this is
discussed in detail in the
textbook.
And this is the Robber's Cave
study.
And this Robber's Cave study
serves as a nice illustration of
morality in everyday life.
The study was,
eleven- and 12-year-old boys at
a camping program.
These were well-adjusted,
pretty rich kids,
racially homogeneous,
and they were put into separate
cabins.
And the cabins were given
leaders and they gave themselves
names.
Being unimaginative boys,
they called themselves "The
Eagles" and "The Rattlers" but
as--what happened was,
being separated they developed
distinctive cultures.
And when these groups were set
in competition against each
other, the Eagles versus the
Rattlers, the within-group
intensity grew.
The Eaglers began--Eagles began
to care a lot more about other
Eagles than about anybody else.
So, there's within-group
solidarity.
And then there were negative
stereotypes.
So, these groups developed
different cultures.
It was a randomly cut
apart--kind of like Yale College
is actually, where you get a
random assortment of people.
But despite the fact that the
assortment is random,
the division is random,
cultures begin to emerge.
The Eagles prided themselves on
being clean living,
not using cuss words and
treating each other with
respect.
They viewed the Rattlers as
dirty and tough and kind of
slovenly slobs.
The Rattlers viewed the Eagles
as goody-goody kids.
It's cruel.
Finally, [laughter]
it all evolved into
hostilities, raids and violence.
The Eagles burnt a Rattlers
banner, cuss words were
occasionally used,
and so Sherif,
the psychologist designing all
of this, went,
"Excellent," [laughter]
and then the problem--He then
says,
"Now we've created two
different warring cultures.
That was fun.
[laughter]
What do we do to make them
friends again?
And then we figure out how
to--now we've done that and
this'll solve all sorts of
problems."
So they started off.
They wanted to have--They set
up peace talks where a
representative of the Eagle and
a representative of the Rattler
were set to meet and plan ways
so that they could disarm and
stop using cuss words and
everything like that.
This failed.
The kids who engaged in the
peace talks were ostracized by
their own groups as treasonists.
That failed.
They decided to set up
individual competitions like the
Olympics where they--where
people wouldn't compete as
Eagles or Rattlers but rather
they would compete as
individuals.
That failed too.
Like the Olympics,
people--the teams took
their--they took their
individual accomplishments as
reflecting on the group and it
evolved into Eagles versus The
Rattlers.
They shared meals,
they turned--which turned into
food fights and more cuss words.
They shared movies,
more fights,
more cuss words.
They shared fun with
firecrackers,
[laughter]
which was a disastrous thing
which nearly brought the
experiment to an end.
[laughter]
They brought in a religious
figure to give them sermons on
brotherly love.
[laughter]
The sermons were entirely
unsuccessful.
What's interesting is they--the
Eagle--they took them to heart.
These were good kids.
They were respectful of
religious authority but the
lessons they took from them is
"I should learn to love my
neighbor."
If I'm a Rattler,
I should learn to love my
fellow Rattler and appreciate
him as a fellow,
as a person.
"I love him.
It's love, not like those
scummy Eagles."
[laughter] They all failed.
Here's what worked.
Sherif told the kids--all of
the kids--that the water line to
the camp was cut and they all
had to defend the camp.
What this did was it
established a super ordinate
goal, that is a goal that
everybody shared,
and perhaps more important a
common enemy.
This is where the solution,
by the way, to bringing
together--and you could write
this down--to bringing together
all the warring countries and
religions of this planet is an
alien attack.
[laughter]
By the logic of the Sherif it
will bring us all together as a
group.
A different question is,
there in that experiment the
"groupiness" was established in
a very powerful way.
They lived separately,
they interacted with each
other, they had their own names.
The psychologist Tajfel after
World War II was interested in
the question of what could make
a group.
In other words,
what do I have to do to you to
put you in a different group
from him?
What do I have to do to this
class--this side of the class to
put you in a different group
from this side and different
from that side?
And what would I have to do for
those groups to matter such
that, for instance,
if I separate you in one group
and you're in another group and
I give you a hundred dollars
will you give the money more to
him or to him,
will you give it more to your
own group or to another group?
And what he found was you don't
need much.
In one experiment he showed
people pictures of modern art
and based on their responses he
described them as Klee lovers or
Kandinsky lovers.
Now, this is all made up.
They were just random
assignments but the Klee lovers
viewed themselves as more
similar to other Klee lovers.
They thought the Klee lovers
tended to be smarter than the
Kandinsky lovers and the Klee
lovers would devote more
resources to themselves than to
others.
This is why it's called
"minimal groups."
You don't need much to make you
into a group.
And in fact,
later experiments just flipped
a coin.
So the lot--the experiment goes
like this.
I ask everybody in this class
to take out a coin.
You all flip it.
Everyone who has heads,
you're one group.
Everyone who has tails,
you're the other group.
Then I ask people in the heads
group, "Which group do
you--Putting yourself aside,
which group on average do you
think is smarter?"
You'd say, "Well,
you know, it kind of works out
that the heads group is kind of
really--heads,
smart."
Which group--"Here is some
money.
You have to distribute it."
You're more likely--It's a
subtle effect when you make the
groups so minimal but you're
more likely to give it to your
own group than to others and
this suggests that moral
feelings are exquisitely attuned
not necessarily only to
individuals but also to the
psychology of groups.
Any questions at this point
about moral feelings?
Yes.
Student:
How you formed the groups--How
is that morality?
Professor Paul Bloom:
It's morality--It bears on
morality because it bears
on--So,
the question is,
"How does group membership,
how does that relate to the
topic of morality?"
And the answer is the moral
feelings we're talking about are
feelings like empathy and
caring.
For me to have a moral feeling
towards you means you matter to
me.
If you were to be harmed,
I would view it as wrong.
And the group experiment
suggests that the extent to
which these moral feelings
operate are partially determined
by the groups to which we belong
to.
If I'm American and you're from
another country,
I will view myself--this is a
very--kind of obvious
finding--my obligations to you
will be seen as less than if you
were another American.
If I'm a Klee lover and you're
a Kandinsky lover,
I don't think you quite deserve
as much as me.
Moral judgment is an area that
is tremendously exciting and
there's a lot of recent research
on this.
By moral judgment I mean not
empathetic feelings,
not feelings of caring and love
or approval and disapproval,
so they're not feelings of
caring and love and empathy,
but notions like something is
good or bad,
something--like something is
fair or unfair.
So, there are three hallmarks
for moral judgments.
So, suppose I say I don't like
strawberry ice cream.
That's an evaluation.
That's a judgment but it's not
a moral judgment.
Why not?
Because I don't think it
carries a sense of obligation.
I don't think anybody's obliged
to eat or not to eat strawberry
ice cream.
And it doesn't carry a notion
of sanctions,
meaning I don't think anybody
should be punished for eating
strawberry ice cream.
On the other hand,
if I say I don't like baby
killers, that actually is a
moral judgment in my case.
So [inaudible]
I say, "Well,
I don't like baby killers.
You like to kill babies.
I actually think we are obliged
not to kill babies."
If you disagree with me,
you're wrong and you should
stop killing those babies.
[laughter]
Should you fail to stop killing
those babies,
I think you should be punished
for killing babies."
And that's what my judgment
about "no killing babies" makes
it a moral judgment.
Now, some people attempted to
look at this the wrong way and
say, "Look.
What a weird topic, morality.
I don't believe in morality.
I believe in Nietzsche.
I don't believe in ethics," but
I don't believe you if you were
to say that because morality
isn't--morality as we talk about
it in this context isn't just
regarding your position on big
questions like political issues
or big moral questions like
abortion or capital punishment.
Rather, some sort of moral
judgment happens all the time,
often unconsciously.
So, as you live your life you
have to answer questions like
what should you eat?
Any moral vegetarians here?
I'm just raising my hand to
encourage people.
[laughter] Okay.
Anybody give to charity?
Anybody not give to charity?
Good.
[laughter]
Different from the moral
vegetarians I noticed.
Who do you socialize with?
There's homeless people around
Yale and New Haven.
What do you give to them?
Do you avoid their eyes?
Do you--What do you want to do
with your life?
Who do you have sex with?
Under what context or
conditions?
These are moral questions.
My favorite moral dilemma is as
I'm walking down the street and
I see somebody I sort of know,
do I avoid eye so we don't have
a conversation [laughter]
or do I say,
"Hey.
How are you doing?"
or do I kind of do the nod
hoping that there won't be more
than this nod?
[laughter]
And then after I leave and I
say, "Oh, I should have made eye
contact with that person.
I'm such a jerk.
[laughter]
There is a homeless person"
and--but these are day-to-day
moral questions we struggle with
all the time and so there's a
centrality in the study of how
we do moral reasoning.
So, what do we know about moral
reasoning?
Well, we know that there are
some universals.
There are some aspects of moral
reasoning that show up
everywhere on earth.
And there is some evidence,
though it's not particularly
strong at this point,
that these same intuitions show
up in young children and in
nonhuman primates like
chimpanzees,
capuchins, macaques and so on.
And these are things like anger
at cheaters, gratitude toward
sharers, the sort of things
you'd expect to come out in a
prisoner's dilemma,
feelings that some things are
right and some things are wrong.
These are foundational.
But at the same time the study
of moral reasoning is a
fascinated--fascinating issue
for those of us interested in
cross-cultural psychology
because there are plain
differences across cultures.
So, the anthropologist Richard
Shweder gives a list here of
human differences:
People have found it
quite natural to be
spontaneously appalled,
outraged,
indignant, proud,
disgusted, guilty and ashamed
by all sorts of things.
Then there's a long list:
"masturbation,
homosexuality,
sexual abstinence,
polygamy,
abortion, circumcision,
corporal punishment,
capital punishment,
Islam, Christianity,
Judaism, capitalism,
democracy, flag burning,
miniskirts, long hair,
no hair,
blah blah, parents and children
sleeping in the same bed,
parents and children not
women being allowed to work,
women not being allowed to
work.
If I put it down in a list and
got people to tick it off,
what you all thought,
there would be some
differences.
Some of you think meat eating
is okay.
Some of you do not.
Some of you--You might have
different views about divorce.
Most of you believe women
should be allowed to work.
Most of you will be in favor or
not morally scolding of
homosexuality.
You'll be lukewarm about
polygamy.
Nobody would like abstinence
and so on.
[laughter]
But if we gave that same list
to people in a different
culture, they'd tick off
entirely different things.
These are ways in which people
vary.
I don't think people vary in
their feelings about baby
killing.
I don't think people vary about
the feelings of I do something
for you and then you don't do
something for me.
I think that's gut-level,
hard-wired, evolved to solve
prisoner's dilemmas.
But these are important issues
and these vary a lot from
culture to culture and a good
theory of psychology has to
explain how these differences
arise.
And Shweder has a theory which
is quite interesting.
Shweder argues that there are
three styles of thought,
three different frameworks of
moral thought,
three different ethics.
There's an ethics of autonomy.
This is what moral philosophers
within our culture view as
morality, notions of rights,
of equality,
of freedom.
But many cultures focus on an
ethics of community,
bringing together duty,
status, hierarchy,
and interdependence.
Other cultures focused more on
an ethics of divinity where
notions such as purity,
sanctity, pollution and sin are
relevant.
So for example,
when we're talking about the
rights of men and women and what
they should be allowed to do,
many people in our society
following an ethics of autonomy
will argue that they should have
equal rights in all domains of
behavior.
Since they are sentient,
free creatures,
they should have a right to do
whatever they want unless there
is a compelling argument against
it and a compelling argument
would have to involve some
infringement of the freedom of
other people.
On the other hand,
if you're in an ethics of
community you might argue that
men and women have different
rights and different
responsibilities.
They may be born to perform
certain things and as such
they're duty bound to follow
them.
If you're from an ethics of
divinity, you may appeal to
religious injunctions against
certain actions and behaviors
and these may differentially
restrict the behavior of men and
women.
You might believe for instance,
that women should not prepare
food when menstruating because
it would contaminate the food.
You may believe that
there's--there are severe
restrictions about who could
have sex with one another that
don't have to do with human
rights and human freedom.
It has to do with the way
things should be because of
issues of pollution and sin.
Now, Western cultures,
as I've said,
are highly invested in an
ethics of autonomy and so
debates we have in our culture
tend to be framed in terms of an
ethics of autonomy.
If we have a debate about
abortion in this class,
people--some people might say,
"Look.
The fetus is a sentient being
and as such it has a right to
survive and shouldn't be killed
by its mother."
Other people would argue, "No.
A woman has full freedom over
her own body and as long as a
fetus is within the body
they--she has a right to control
it."
If we're arguing about hate
speech, we could talk about the
balance between the rights of
the freedom of speech versus the
right to a certain quality of
education free of harassment and
humiliation.
Those are the ways we frame
things but one of the more
interesting discoveries in this
field is that although people
think that they're governed by
the ethics of autonomy,
even people within our culture,
even highly educated people
within our culture,
even people like you show moral
judgments that are not quite as
simple.
So, this is the work of
Jonathan Haidt at University of
Virginia.
And Haidt finds if you ask
people, they believe in our
culture that they hold to an
ethics of autonomy.
If it doesn't harm anyone,
it's okay.
So, if I was to ask you your
attitudes about sex,
most of you--not all of you,
you come from different
cultures, you have different
attitudes--but most of you would
say sex between consenting
adults is okay as long as nobody
gets hurt,
as long as nobody gets hurt
people's rights are respected.
So, gay marriage,
for instance,
or gay sex would be okay with
you because it is--nobody is
harmed and these are consenting
adults.
Haidt points out that there are
certain problems with this
argument and he illustrates this
problem--these problems with
stories like this:
Julie and Mark are
brother and sister.
They are traveling together in
France on summer vacation from
college.
One night they are staying
alone in a cabin near the beach.
They decide it would be
interesting and fun if they
tried making love.
At the very least,
it would be a new experience
for each of them.
Julie was already taking birth
control pills but Mark uses a
condom too just to be safe.
They both enjoy making love but
they decide not to do it again.
They keep that night a special
secret which makes them feel
even closer to each other.
What do you think about that?
Was it okay for them to make
love?
Who says yes?
Good.
I know that some people would
say yes, shoot up their hands,
and they look around in
astonishment that no one else is
with them.
[laughter] Who says no?
Okay.
Who is not sure?
You're not sure.
That's the weirdest of all.
[laughter]
Haidt finds that the
distribution even among this--If
you--Look.
If you go home and you ask your
parents, they say,
"Ew.
What is--What are you learning
at Yale?"
[laughter]
This is a very unusual culture
and where some people will say
it's okay.
What Haidt finds is most people
say it doesn't and then he
simply asks them,
being a good psychologist,
"Okay.
What's wrong with it?"
And this is the brother/sister
case.
And the responses are
interesting.
Because people view themselves
as committed to an ethics of
autonomy, they can't just say
it's disgusting.
So, they exhibit what Haidt
describes as "moral
dumbfounding," meaning that they
struggle to find an explanation.
They say it's terrible because
they'll have a kid and the
kid'll grow up freaky [laughter]
and then the experimenter--it's
an interview situation--says,
"Well, no.
Remember they're both using a
lot of birth control."
"Maybe she's under age."
"No, not under age."
And finally,
"Well, it's just wrong."
Similarly, another one of the
scenarios--[laughter]
This isn't as bad as you might
expect.
[laughter]
The family dog is playing
outside and gets hit by a car.
[laughter]
They bring it in and they say,
"Oh, Fido's dead,
Fido's dead,
but what's for dinner?"
So, they cook it and eat it.
Who says it's okay?
Good.
[laughter]
Who says it's not okay?
Okay.
Then they notice that their
toilet is kind of dirty.
"But whoa, there is an American
flag."
[laughter]
They then use the toilet to
clean the flag.
Who says that's okay?
[laughter]
Anybody think it's not okay?
And just keep in mind we're
getting sort of even responses
here.
On all of these,
the majority of people who are
not college students in elite
universities say,
"Oh, that's so wrong."
Finally, there is this one.
And this one really is as bad
as one might expect.
[laughter]
A guy is lonely so he purchases
a frozen chicken from the
supermarket, brings it home and
has relations with it.
[laughter]
Then he cooks it and eats it.
[laughter] Look.
This is a scientific paper in
the Psych Review.
[laughter]
Okay.
Who says that's okay?
[laughter] Good.
And I notice there is
consistency among people.
The people who think it's okay
have every right to say that
they believe,
if they really,
sincerely believe it's okay,
they are committed to an ethics
of autonomy.
Those of you who think it's not
okay, none of these,
should ask yourself why and
should then scrutinize your
reasons.
People are very smart and they
could present--easily present
reasons why.
They could say,
"Oh, disease," but these
reasons tend not to be sincere.
If you take away the
considerations that the reaction
stays.
And these are then interesting
case studies of how our moral
judgment is governed by factors
that we might not be conscious
of.
Our moral intuitions can
surprise us.
The motivation for Milgram's
work, and this is the final
thing we'll talk about in the
context of morality--The
motivation for Milgram's work
was the Holocaust and he was
interested in exploring why such
a thing could happen.
I should note by the way--you
know from the movie that Milgram
was a Yale professor.
He left Yale when he didn't get
tenure, moved to Harvard,
didn't get tenure there too.
He was--He had a reputation by
then as a mad doctor.
He ended up at City University
of New York, became a full
professor at age thirty three,
died in his early '50s,
did not lead a good life but
had extraordinary discoveries.
Another discovery which we'll
talk about next week is--Has
anybody heard the phrase "six
degrees of separation?"
Milgram, and we'll talk about
that later.
Milgram had a powerful
imagination.
Okay.
So we know--This is all review.
There is the guy.
How many of you laughed when
you saw the movie ?
Interesting question why and
we'll talk about that in a
little while.
Shocks, "slight shock" to "XXX."
There is--This is just
repeating what you've seen.
The learner protests as he's
being shocked more and more but
the experimenter continues to
request obedience.
For those of you who haven't
seen the movie,
again, the setup is someone is
a subject.
They don't know--They think
that they're teaching somebody
in a memory game but actually
the person who is being shocked
is a confederate who is trained
to react in certain ways as he's
being increasingly shocked.
And the finding is that the
majority of people will deliver
fatal shocks to this person who
they had never met based on the
instructions of another person.
Now, there are some immediate
bad explanations for this.
One explanation is these are
really strange people.
"These are an abnormal group of
psychopaths."
But we know that's not true.
It's been replicated with many
subjects.
There's no reason to believe
that the subjects in Milgram's
original study were in any way
unusual.
It's also a misreading to say
that people are,
in general, sadistic.
You remember from the movie
nobody got pleasure from giving
the shocks.
They felt acutely
uncomfortable,
embarrassed,
conflicted, under a huge amount
of stress.
They weren't liking doing this.
There were follow-up studies.
This is the original study.
If you take it away from Yale,
some of the authority goes
away, and similarly,
the extent to which there are
fatal shocks goes down.
As the teacher is with the
learner next to him,
it goes down.
If you have to put the guy's
hand on it, you're less likely
to kill him.
If the experimenter gives you
instructions by phone,
you're less likely to do it.
If an ordinary man,
not the guy in a white lab coat
but an ordinary guy,
says,
"Hey, keep shocking him,
that's okay," you're less
likely to do it,
and if there is a rebellion,
if somebody else rebels and
says, "I won't do it," you are
much more likely not to do it
yourself.
There are some--Oh, sorry.
Yeah, and if you could get to
choose your own shock level,
you could keep--then very,
very few people go all the way.
So, these are an important list
of factors as to the factors
that can make somebody less
likely to bring it up to the
killing level.
And as a result we can look at
those factors and think about
what is the perfect situation
for making somebody do something
like this and the perfect
situation not to.
Some more serious critiques of
Milgram: Milgram's experiment is
why we have human-subjects
committees.
This is a terribly stressful
experiment to do to people and,
as I say now about a lot of
studies that I describe in this
class,
it would not today be done.
People did say they were happy
to have participated and only 2%
said that they were sorry,
but still serious damage could
have been done and perhaps was
done.
These people left the lab
having learnt about themselves
that they'll kill another person
if someone tells them to,
and as psychologists I don't
think we have any right to do
that to people.
I think people can learn
this--these things about
themselves.
We have no right to put you in
a circumstance where you believe
you killed somebody and then
tell you it was just pretend--we
just made you kill somebody.
And that's a serious ethical
criticism.
Historians and sociologists
have brought in things back to
the questions that Milgram was
interested in and argue--and
this is controversial--the
extent to which obedience really
is a good model for acts of
genocide.
So, just to take one example
among many, Goldhagen argued
that the participants in Nazi
Germany and in the Holocaust
were actually not people who
were obediently following orders
but rather were enthusiastic,
people who volunteered to do it.
Still Milgram's work is
interesting in many--for many
reasons, in large part because
he provides an illustration of
the perfect situation for
getting somebody to do a
terrible thing and the perfect
situation has certain
ingredients.
It includes authority,
in this case the authority of
Yale and the authority of
science.
"This is an experiment that
must go on."
The notion of a self-assured
experimenter--The results would
be very different if the
experimenter himself seemed
nervous,
unwilling to proceed,
confused, but he was confident
and he kept saying that he will
take responsibility.
There was distance between the
learner and the experimenter.
Recall you get less of an
effect if you have to touch the
guy but distance makes it easier
for you to kill him.
And finally,
there's a new situation and no
model of how to behave.
One of the reasons why the
Milgram experiment is so nice to
know is that if this ever
happens to you,
not as an experiment but in
real life, it will no longer be
new to you.
You'll know what sort of thing
this is and you'll be able to
examine it in that light.
I want to end this lecture
summing up, drawing a lot upon
Milgram and some other work,
and talk first about two forces
for evil and then to end by
talking about two forces for
good.
The first force for evil is
deindividuation of self.
And what this means is--one
reason why people are so bad in
groups is because you could
diffuse your responsibility.
If I'm running through the
street alone with a baseball bat
smashing through windows,
it's me and I know it's me.
If I'm with twenty other
people, it's not me anymore.
It's part of the group and I
don't feel as bad.
Responsibility becomes diffuse.
One of the powers of a group
then is it diminishes
responsibility.
You could diminish
responsibility in other ways.
Another way of diminishing
responsibility is you could
accept orders.
It's not me.
I'm just an instrument of
somebody else telling me what to
do.
And yet another way of
diminishing responsibility is
anonymity.
Here's a question.
In so many violent acts and so
many people go to war,
what they do is they paint
their faces or they put on
masks.
Why?
Well, there's anonymity from
others.
If I'm wearing a mask as I do
my terrible stuff,
nobody will know it's me,
but there's also a
psychologically liberating
effect.
If I'm anonymous,
it's not me and I could do
terrible things without feeling
the same moral responsibility.
This analysis has explained why
people don't always help others
in need.
If there's a group,
responsibility to help
decreases and this is captured
in different ways but the main
idea is we all think someone
else will help so we don't.
There's a diffusion.
This just summarizes some
studies--some famous studies
supporting this.
And the classic example,
which is discussed in detail in
the textbook,
is the Kitty Genovese case
where somebody was murdered in
the common lot that apartment
buildings surrounded while
dozens of people watched,
dozens of good,
normal people watched and did
nothing.
If there's some advice I've
heard on this,
which is pretty good advice:
If you're ever in a predicament
on a city street,
you have a heart attack,
you broke your leg,
you're being mugged and
everything,
and there's--this is based on
the research,
screaming "Help" is often not
very successful because if I'm
with ten people and there's
somebody screaming "Help,"
I look at the other nine people.
They're not doing anything.
They're looking at me.
I'm not doing anything.
We keep walking.
What is useful is point to
somebody and say,
"You in the green sweater,
call the police,"
and the psychological evidence
is if you--if somebody's--if I
am wearing the green sweater and
somebody asks me to call the
police I will call the police.
I'm a good guy.
I wouldn't sit aside when
somebody's being harmed.
On the other hand,
if somebody says,
"Somebody call the police,"
well, I got things to do and so
diffusion of responsibility
explains both when we're willing
to do terrible things and also
when we're willing to help
people who are in trouble.
Denigration of others.
There's a lot of ways to make
other people matter less.
So, this is the flip side.
The way to do terrible
things--One way to do terrible
things is to lose yourself so
you're not an individual anymore
but another way to do terrible
things is so that the person
you're doing it to isn't an
individual.
How do you do that?
Well, you have psychological
distance or physical distance.
I'm more likely to kill you if
you're very far away than if
you're close.
I don't--I could describe you
and start to think about you not
as a person and language can be
used for this.
Instead of people you could use
terms like "cargo," instead of
murder, extermination.
Humor is very powerful in
denigrating and demoting people.
When you start laughing at
somebody you think of them as
less of a person and we'll get
to that a little bit more when
we talk about laughter.
You could take away their names.
One of the more interesting
things in the United Nations
Declaration of Human Rights is a
very interesting right.
It says, "Every person has a
right to a name."
And you might think what a
strange right but there's a
cleverness to it.
When you take away somebody's
name they matter less.
People have names.
People have distinct,
individual names that mark them
as people and once you know
somebody's name you are less
likely to do bad things to them.
And another option which I'm
interested in from the
standpoint of my own research is
you could see them as
disgusting.
Disgust is what Paul Rozin has
called "the body and soul
emotion."
And we know certain things
about disgust.
It is a human universal.
It is a basic emotion with a
characteristic facial
expression.
Remember Paul Ekman's work on
the basic emotions,
the universals of emotional
expression?
Disgust is one of them and it
is universally elicited by
certain things like this list.
Wherever you go,
feces, urine,
blood, vomit,
rotten flesh and most meat will
be disgusting.
Now, if that was all we had to
say about disgust,
it wouldn't affect morality
very much but we know that
people can be seen as
disgusting.
And Charles Darwin actually,
who was an astute observer of
human behavior,
tells a nice story to
illustrate this:
how "a native touched with his
finger some cold preserved meat
and plainly showed disgust at
its softness whilst I felt utter
disgust at my food being touched
by a naked savage though his
hands did not appear dirty."
People can be disgusting and if
people are seen as disgusting
they matter less.
The philosopher and legal
scholar Martha Nussbaum nicely
summarizes this:
"Thus,
throughout history certain
disgust properties have
repeatedly and monotonously been
associated with Jews,
women, homosexuals,
untouchables,
lower class people.
All of those are imagined as
tainted by the dirt of the
body."
Any--I won't read this but this
is a typical bit of Nazi
propaganda.
Any genocidal movement that has
left behind a written record has
been shown to use the mechanism
of disgust to dehumanize people
and make them easier to kill.
I'll skip that.
I want to end though on a
positive note.
And the positive note are
forces for good.
So, forces for bad are to lose
yourself as an individual,
lose yourself in a crowd,
lose yourself because there is
some authority using you as an
instrument, lose yourself
because you're anonymous,
plus treat others not as
people, as numbers,
as objects, as disgusting
things,
but there are some forces for
good.
These include "contact" and
"interdependence."
What this often--What this can
be viewed as,
as an extended version of
selfish gene theory,
which is that to the extent
you're interconnected with other
people you care about them more
for purely selfish reasons.
Robert Wright presented this in
a very blunt way,
but I think his quote is quite
moving: "One of the many reasons
I don't want to bomb the
Japanese is that they built my
minivan."
And the idea is he has economic
codependence with these people.
They're a different group.
He might want to kill them
under normal circumstances but
the interdependence gives rise
to a moral connection.
Thomas Friedman proposed the
"Golden Arches Theory of Human
Conflict," which said that no
two countries which each have a
McDonald's will ever go to war
because McDonald's forces global
interdependence.
This was falsified in the NATO
bombing of, I think,
Sarajevo but still his heart's
in the right place,
the idea that interconnection
makes you more likely to get
along with other people.
More generally,
there's what's been called "The
Contact Hypothesis."
So, interdependence is one
thing but what's maybe more
interesting is that simple
contact with other people.
Particularly if you're of equal
status, you have a common goal,
and you have social support
makes you like people more.
There are now dozens,
probably hundreds,
of studies that show that
people who would otherwise show
animosity towards one another,
like blacks and whites in the
United States,
like each other more if they're
brought together.
And there's a lot of social
psychology research as to the
conditions in which you have to
bring them together.
The Robber's Cave study talked
about before is a nice example.
It was not easy to bring them
together but when they had a
common goal that brought
them--that caused the
interconnection and then the
contact led to moral feeling.
The military is a superb
example.
The military in the United
States was a situation which
brought together people who
wouldn't otherwise have any
contact and they liked each
other.
There has been study after
study showing that people in the
military who were otherwise,
for instance,
racists after working with
people of different races liked
them more because you had all of
the right ingredients.
You had--They had--They worked
together for a common goal,
the military supported bringing
these people together,
and they were brought together
on an equal and fair footing.
There is, of course,
a lot of debate about
universities like Yale to the
extent in which they promote
interdependence--sorry,
they promote positive contact
between groups.
And you could think of yourself
as an exercise.
If these are the conditions for
contact, to what extent are they
met in the university setting
between,
say blacks and whites,
people from the American South
versus people from the American
North,
people from other countries
versus people from the United
States?
And I know there's debate on
campus about the extent to which
there is segregation within the
Yale community.
And you could ask yourself
the--about the extent of that
segregation and how that
reflects--what role that should
play with regard to the Contact
Hypothesis.
Finally, and this is the last
thing I'll say:
If you take another person's
perspective, you'll care more
about them.
This is the final force for
good from a moral perspective.
JFK, when making the plea for
equal rights,
didn't produce an abstract
philosophical argument but
rather tried to invite his
listeners who were white to
engage in perspective taking.
If an American,
because his skin is dark,
cannot eat lunch in a
restaurant open to the
public--[and so on and so on and
so on],
then who among us would be
content to have the color of his
skin changed and stand in his
place?
Who among us would be content
with the counsels of patience
and delay?
Again, Nussbaum goes on and
talks about how in Greek
dramas--Greek dramas invited
people to take the perspectives
of those who they would never
imaginably be or even be in
contact with and argue that this
gave--led to an empathetic
expansion.
I think one of the greatest
circles for moral good is
storytelling where you're
invited to take the perspective
of another and see the world as
they do.
Finally, there are direct ways.
You can ask people--and this is
a way which we talk to our
children when we try to get our
children to expand their moral
concern of compassion.
We say, "Try to see it from
their point of view.
How would you feel if--"Then
there's indirect ways.
You can, for instance,
use the power of metaphor.
There could be familiar things
that you are close to and you
could bring in together new
things as falling under the
rubric of these familiar things.
So, if I wanted to cause you to
feel moral concern for a fetus,
I would do well to describe it
as a pre-born child.
If I wanted you to care about
an animal, I would do well to
describe it as if it were human.
If I wanted to think about all
of you and get--and establish
more of a connection with you,
I would not describe you as
unrelated strangers.
Rather, you are my brothers and
my sisters.
And of course,
any political movement that
tries to bring us
together--people together
says--uses a family metaphor.
Finally, when Steven Spielberg
tried to get us to entertain the
notion that computers and robots
are sentient moral beings he did
not show us one that looked like
this .
He showed us one that looked
like that .
Okay.
The reading response for next
week is a simple one.
I know I've been giving
difficult reading responses.
This is simple.
You could write it up very
short and that will be a passing
grade if you just write it up
very short.
You could also write it up a
bit longer.
Suppose the Milgram experiment
had never been done and it was
being done for the first time
here.
What would you do?
What do you think everyone else
would do?
Okay.
I'll see you next week.